tell us about Forbes now it's not the
financial magazine what is the acronym
for Forbes now very different than the
financial magazine Forbes is the
Fraternal Order of real bearded Santa's
it's a place where all these Santa's can
get together and have some community
they share stories that have an annual
luncheon that they do every year in
February I believe we'll all get
together and ride a mountain berry park
and ride some rides and then they all go
on a cruise down to the Caribbean it's a
way for them to get through the Santa of
the sort of post-christmas depression
that a lot of these guys go through and
I didn't really know anything about that
until we started to make the movie but
apparently most of these guys go through
a post-christmas depression when it's
all over because they're so used to
being the center of attention for so
long there's such a build-up coming to
Christmas that finally on December 26
when it's all over there's a huge
letdown a lot of these guys you know
sort of get sick illnesses a thing just
sort of been pushing off and pushing off
throughout the whole Christmas season
now all of a sudden they get overwhelmed
by is a little bit of depression that
goes on when all of a sudden you're not
you know what everybody's looking for
what everybody wants to talk to and what
everybody wants to see all of a sudden
anymore so Forbes is a place that they
can all get together they have this
luncheon and they talk about you know
their designers who come in and they can
get new custom suits bill it's it's just
an organization that provides support
for these guys in the community yeah
I've heard similar things about
musicians that come off tour I'll go
through a depression as well for those
who want to see becoming Santa in the
theater what's the situation with that
well unfortunately were not in theaters
this year maybe that could change I'm
not sure when when we set out to make
this movie I definitely thought it was a
theatrical
movie and we were definitely pushing
towards that it just seemed to make
sense to me I mean you've got dropping
the theaters between Thanksgiving let it
run for Christmas and you've got a huge
built-in audience I mean people are just
dying for Christmas content between that
time it seemed like a no-brainer for me
dropping the theaters and I think people
come see it but what I learned along the
way through all the distributor's we
were talking to is it seems like for
small independent movies like ours it's
very difficult to make a profit in a
theater I mean of course big you know
tentpole movies like spider-man and
mission impossible or they're going to
make tons of money but for us it's a
different ballgame I mean just to get it
into limited release in just a few
cities by the time you make the prints
and it's the advertising that kills you
in these cities you know and they just
felt like it would it would be a loss
for us and I'm still not a hundred
percent convinced of that but they're
the professionals so I have to I have to
go with what they say so instead of
instead of theatre as we go in fee OD
and DVD and you know they're really
pushing the VOD thing right now and the
numbers are there it does seem like you
know vo DS legitimate and they kind of
told me the dvds are dead and I think
the Sun is setting long DVDs but I don't
think it's set yet and especially with
this movie it was really important for
me to make sure we had a DVD deal for
this movie because I feel like it's a
Christmas movie and it's a gift
something by give out and I think it
also is for adults and I think you know
myself included come from the generation
that you know you want to have a hard
copy something I like buying dvds I like
having a collection of dvds and sure I
download things also and do VOD but it's
nice to have that collection I like to
look at all pull movies out and rewatch
it or listen with directors commentary
or rewatch scenes and things like that
so I felt like it was important to to
make sure this was on DVD